of the day and I had been watching all
the presentations we had so far there's
gonna be a little different talk what I
want to do is show some problems that we
solved around energy systems that have a
large practical value but we haven't
really found good ways to analyze and
obtain theoretical results and maybe
improve the algorithms that we have so
this can serve maybe as a motivation for
looking again at these problems and
coming up with new ways to address them
so many other speakers talked about
challenges that you're seeing in the
energy system so here's the traditional
energy system which is a hierarchical
system where generation follows load and
it's currently optimized and scheduled
in a centralized way what's happening
today is that we are seeing the
appearance of a lot of different
resources first of all in the generation
side we're starting to see the adoption
of renewables and potentially storage in
the future as well as in the
distribution side consumers are starting
to adopt things like electric vehicles
solar panels and smart appliances one
big question that is around this system
is how can we coordinate all of the
resources consumers have so that we can
start shaping the demand to follow the
supply in order to do that there is some
important challenges the first one is
that in the system as it is trans the
transmission network is very well known
and well modeled and it's extremely
reliable to send power from one place to
the other that's not the case around the
distribution network second we need to
understand how to start coordinating a
large number of these resources using
things like the cloud and so on so forth
so typically we are coordinating around
10,000 to 20,000 things here here we are
one or two orders of magnitude larger
okay so how is the traditional
coordination would be
if I was trying to say do this for
consumers today it's a very simple idea
let's just assume first that I only have
solar panels and a battery at each
consumer and then I'm also observing
their load which I can really shape or
control the idea is super simple you
just solve an optimization problem where
you minimize the total daily cost over
all the customers subject to various
constraints the physics of the power
flow which has to do with constraints
around this network here the constraints
of the storage operation so both you
know that you can only discharge so much
charge so much and limits and so on and
the fact that since I'm solving this
right now but I do have to take into
account future decisions I need to
somehow model the stochasticity of the
load and finally ideally you want to
take somehow into account the
information architecture if I assume
that I can constantly signal everything
I can potentially imagine this
optimization running in the cloud and
every second just transmitting
information to all my storage units the
information architecture is quite simple
and maybe you can just use MPC or you
can use some other variants of dynamic
programming to sort this out so that's
kind of the traditional problem setting
so in fact the problem is that here we
assume various things first of all we
assume that we knew this physical
network we assume that these loads are
kind of easy to forecast and we assume
that this architecture is simple but in
practice what we are seeing is that
first of all if you go and talk to
utility operators the network model is
not known in fact it can be quite
complicated for example if I am PG&E I
may not know the network model but
potentially I could learn it but if I am
Tesla I may not know the network model
and I may not have access to all the
sensors to learn about it and I have to
start thinking about how am I going to
do this optimization to
into account the various constraints I'm
subject to the second thing is the
information architecture is not simple
and here are some of the issues first of
all it's really unrealistic to expect
the cloud to be able to signal all the
storage devices in real time all the
time and once you start taking that into
account you have to consider two issues
one is the fact that maybe you're
operating under multiple time scales so
one for the storages and the homes which
are making decisions in real time maybe
another one to plan in the cloud to
coordinate things together and the
second issue is that you may face
information delays so for example today
all the smart meters that we have the
data that's collected from them faces
like a certain amount of delay and the
last issue here is that forecasting
loads and renewables is hard so one of
the things that we have been doing at
Stanford is we have had different
projects where we addressed these
questions particularly today we will
talk about the first two one is you know
how to learn these network models so we
came up with a series of statistically
proper practical algorithms for which we
don't really have a very good
performance analysis but they perform
very well in practice including with
data from the utility and so on and I
will show you a little bit about that
and the second one is we have another
project which is looking at this
coordination and what we found is some
algorithms that seem to work well in
simulations and these are really complex
simulations and also we started
implementing on a lab that we have or we
have all these resources for real but
again we need to gain better
understanding of the theoretical
underpinning of that I'm not going to
talk about forecasting today but there
is also a lot to be thought about when
you start to scale forecasting to
hundreds of thousands of these time
series of loads and solar and so on and
how to do it ok so let's just start with
this network model learning
so here's kind of the simple problem
formulation each node here is a node in
my power network and these are the
branches that connect these nodes
together and I have observations which
are the voltage measurement I can assume
that I measure the magnitude of the
voltage and the phase angle so these are
kind of I'm actually looking at the time
signal it's going to be a sine wave of
the voltage I'm gonna take every cycle
and look at the magnitude or maybe every
few you know tens of cycles it's gonna
give me a magnitude and the phase angle
is the phase angle difference between
the sine waves in different locations in
the system okay so that's your typical
measurement maybe you also have a
similar measurement for current and then
the real and reactive power that you're
consuming in each location traditionally
what's happening at the utility level is
that this whole network is not fully
known so for example maybe these
branches that are dotted here are not
know and the question is you want to try
to learn them okay so find what is the
topology in this box so how do you go
about doing that here's kind of a very
simple approach you can go and map this
you know physical problem into a
statistical problem and I can say in
every node I have a measurement and then
edges between these nodes will cause my
joint distribution of the variables to
have certain property and I can use that
property to kind of learn what's going
on so what is that property so here's
the idea that we did you know you can
for example quantize all these
measurements and you can say there's a
Joint Distribution and normally you will
be able to decompose the Joint
Distribution of measurements in that way
for every time instant but if you
actually look at the power network
structure which is a radial Network
which means it's a tree you can actually
assert that there is a conditional
independence between the voltages
and these you have to remember are the
phasers so the voltage magnitude and
phase angle so that you can decompose
this joint distribution in this way in
order to make this assertion it's not
super hard but basically what you have
to assume is that the correlation
between the consumptions of different
users is not super high and even when
this is kind of violated in practice
these algorithms that we try out work
very well using this assumption so the
question is finding that topology is the
same as finding this who is the parent
of every node okay in this setting and
here is what I mentioned before you know
in order to make that assertion all you
need to do is you can write the
equations for voltage and current phaser
relationships in this network and then
demonstrate that as you condition on
this guy the voltages here are going to
be independent and the basic assumption
to do that is that these currents are
independent which in practice translates
to the power consumed that every node is
independent in this first example yes
okay so you do that and basically now
you can there is a host of algorithms
you can use the most popular one being
take the mutual information between the
measurements in the different nodes and
minimize that and tell me which is the
Joint Distribution that kind of
minimizes this quantity so that sorry
that max it minimizes the divergence
which basically maximizes the mutual
information and that you can show it's a
maximum weight at spanning tree problem
and you get a simple algorithm this is a
well-known algorithm called the cheol-ho
algorithm and there's a very nice review
paper on this written by Martin
Wainwright here from Berkeley so the
point is this is a neat algorithm and
then we went about trying it out in a
series of networks there's a bunch of
standard
Network examples so here are some of
them you know this is the 123 bus
example and I'm just showing you some
empirical results here you can see I
erased a certain number of nodes from my
network and I'm checking whether I'm
able to recover them correctly okay and
there's a certain amount of noise that's
added to this which is equivalent to the
noise in the real-world sensors and you
can see the ciao leo algorithm works
well when I have both V and theta which
is consistent with my original
assumption of conditional independence
but even it works well only when I have
the V measurement you can see it also
has a very low error rate and in
contrast there is various practical
approaches and one of the ones that we
compared it to is the traditional one
which is to solve a regression problem
and identify who the nodes are and
that's kind of very poor and the other
one is to linearize the power flow
equations and and go about your business
that way and that also does very poorly
as soon as you have more than five or
ten unknown edges in your system in fact
we tried this method in our paper that
we published about this we have a three
thousand bus example the 209 2998
nodes and we took real data from PG&E we
took the solar data from an R L and we
basically asked this network to be
reconstructed thousands of times so just
can do a stochastic example and in the
thousands of times we ran it has zero
errors which means we had to run ten
thousand times but in the paper we just
note that that okay this algorithm is
super robust yes yeah so we are
considering the injection for each node
to be the sum of the loads minus the
solar
they are not independent right that's
really true yet the algorithm worked
very well that's exactly one of the
questions we had why is that happening
so it's quite challenging to analyze
this algorithm but it is an open
question and that was one of the first
ones yeah the probabilities here in so
you have you can just numerically
calculate so once I quantize the
voltages in different levels
I just calculate the joint distributions
of the of the counts of the data so I
mapped them into I have so are we gonna
show that to you next you can try both
the the quantization is going to be for
both but they're gonna be different for
each so you have to take into account
that mean and the standard deviation we
just took a standard quantizer from the
signal processing book and applied it
here and it worked well but I'll also
show you a second algorithm that does
not do any quantization it's a little
bit more complex but here's one
interesting observation we have data of
different types we had data from smart
meters which is either 30 minutes
average power or 60 minutes average
power but we also had a data set that
allowed us to test this when you have
very high resolution measurements and
kind of what you notice is that you do
need a large time history maybe about a
thousand measurements of this one minute
about a hundred of 30 and then as you
aggregate more it doesn't really help
much so here's one question you know how
do we determine the length but there's
another more important question in
practice today these networks are kind
of static so I could use this algorithm
and this is what we did for Southern
California Edison in a project with
slack we use this algorithm and
corrected the network models for various
feeders that they are using for their
planning but if you think about what's
going to happen in the future these
networks are going to switch far more
often there's more active controls and
ideas like that and one of the questions
is how do you do online learning and
updating with this type of algorithm
it's not very obvious one of the things
that we were thinking about maybe you
can use some kind of change point
detection but if I have thousands of
nodes and I have to detect a change in
each one of them this may be complicated
yes here it was a single phase but we
have an equivalent paper for the three
phase but not just us now after these
papers are published about a year ago
there's a whole literature now around
these methods but in the whole
literature again we do not have any
analysis of why it works as it works but
you will see very similar plots okay so
a third question is here we have to
assume the system is radio well how do
you learn with loops one simple thing
that you can do is kind of look at the
mutual information formulation when you
have loops and just to get quickly by
this the idea is super simple you can
fix one edge assume it and then run your
tree algorithm that will ensure if I
know I have at most one loop that will
find you know one loop and then you can
do that for two loops and so on and you
will get some kind of complexity
exponential complexity and again this is
kind of well known from this literature
this is how these methods are applied
yes
I see I see I'll show you another
alternative yet another way of doing
this which is slightly different which
is maybe you can consider okay I'll look
at the problem again and have a slightly
different description so here I have
again my Joint Distribution of the
measurements and I can observe the same
type of conditional independence
relationship if I consider neighbors
instead of parents so if I have a
general network I just consider
neighbors if I have a radial network I
just consider parents okay and then as
you can expect this is kind of now old
news in the old days you would run
something like Lazo which is what we
wanted to do and here's what we did you
can just take each one of these complex
variables and say okay I'm going to run
a regression there the variable at node
I is regressed against the variables in
the other nodes okay and basically if
there is a conditional if there is a
dependency relationship between these
two nodes this coefficient is going to
be not zero okay and since the
distribution grid is kind of sparse you
can run something like the lasso and one
of the things here is that you need to
be careful is all the variables are
complex so you have to make adjustments
to this algorithm but you can also for
example make changes to this you can
slightly write this formulation slightly
differently and then get something like
what's called the group lasso and and so
on so forth so you can apply various
algorithms from the literature and
basically by finding who the nonzero
elements of beta are you can find the
neighborhood set the structure of the
network the one question though that
will arise is the following observation
right I will have two coefficients when
I regress VJ to VI and VI to VJ how to
make a decision on which whether this
link exists or not
so we wrote this is a maximum likelihood
problem and did the proper thing and it
becomes a criminal toriel problem and
then in fact we just had a simple
heuristic like what's shown here the
simple heuristic says if both the beta's
are non-zero let's assume it's going to
be the edge exists or in case either one
is zero we may also consider the edge
exists but then we do kind of a
combination of all of these rules by
noting the following observation in a
distribution network the magnitude of
the voltage tells me something about how
far things might be from me and then you
can do some heuristic based on that to
combine these two decisions and I can
explain the details of the heuristic
after the talk here and then we ran this
algorithm and again surprisingly or
maybe not so surprisingly does extremely
well so here is another example where we
added loops to a existing radial Network
example and the method works well got
the existing alternative that was out
there in the literature at that time is
some kind of correlation based example
and again if you look at how the error
rate behaves with the amount of data you
may need about a year of data for this
thing to work correctly assuming that
I'm sampling the data every turn if
every hour okay so that's the number of
samples for this to work properly which
is far larger than that mutual
information based algorithm but why is
this the case I don't really know so
that's another question that's left in
there but it seems to work for all the
examples and I think when we submitted
this particular paper reviewers had a
list of like 20 different networks
you're supposed to run to get it
published so we ran it on all of those
again it seems to work but we don't know
why now the question of online learning
in the setting is also interesting I
think there's two challenges here one is
itself how to do it given that you need
a lot of
but suppose I'm here I already learned
something correctly from that point
onwards can I learn changes in the
network and how to do that correctly is
not necessarily known today okay so this
is one example of a power problem that
can take us to think about these methods
and advance them more fundamentally so
now I want to go into a different
problem and this is actually about
scheduling the DRS and this actually
joint work with with Thomas and Kyle who
are two PhD students and Abbas was
sitting there in the audience so what I
want to look into is what happens when
you have different information
architectures and how do we do this
optimization but in order to motivate
that here's kind of a short motivation
so I'm gonna take this example of a
distribution network it's a 47 bus
network and for each node here I'm going
to aggregate about between 20 to 30
homes and I just want to run what
happens when I add solar and storage to
this so since I have five minutes so
here is one observation if every home is
subject to time-of-use prices which are
high in the middle of the day and low
elsewhere you can expect that if I have
a battery I will charge here and
discharge there okay that's kind of the
cost minimizing action and then
arbitrage profit is the money you make
over this operation of buying and
selling and so on so it's whatever you
receive as a payment minus the cost okay
in terms of the constraints in the
network I definitely want to keep the
voltage deviations at a minimum so
traditionally in your optimal power flow
you're gonna consider voltage and all
the locations in the network as a
constraint what we did is if you in fact
look at practical systems there is a lot
of voltage violations so you can
actually penalize them and if you choose
this penalty
carefully it characterizes kind of the
existing performance in the system today
so what we are going to say is we have
this electric power quality metric which
captures the voltage constraints and
here is kind of what it looks like okay
and if we looked at what happens in this
system as the solar penetration
increases you're going to see that these
voltage violations are going to reduce
as I get more solar because loads are
getting reduced at some point and then
when the solar penetration goes higher
than that then this voltage violations
start to increase and this kind of what
we see in practice today where they say
ok and how I there's too much solar we
are seeing voltage issues now if I added
storage into this picture I can actually
look into that and also notice that
here's different penetration levels of
storage and you can see that as you add
more storage
maybe the violations go higher in the
beginning at the low penetration of
solar because everybody is discharging
at the same time therefore it's very
unlike very likely that maybe you're
violating the lower bound of the
voltages when you're discharging the
batteries everywhere in this network ok
and in fact what you will notice is we
did some simulation studies so Thomas
ran this for us and he found out that
when you have different types of
policies if I allow you to net meter
which is what is there today you have a
higher number of violations but
obviously you can get more cost but if I
don't allow you to net beter meaning I
can't average all the power that I sent
into the network over all time and get
compensated for that then I'm going to
actually have less the cost is going to
be lower here but then I have less
violations but the one thing that we
could potentially do is do coordination
and through coordination maybe achieve a
balance between these two things so now
the coordination challenge here is the
interesting observation first of all
there's actually three players in the
system are at least two players
the network operator the guy who manages
this distribution network like PG&E in
California and then you have the D our
providers these are the guys like Tesla
who have access to the private cloud
they can read the information in your
batteries and maybe send signals and go
optimize them if I want to create a
system to satisfy this maybe I want to
incorporate this issue as a constraint
as well so the fact that we have these
two types of operators and maybe we want
them to cooperate somehow but the second
issue that we need to take into account
is the simple observation that whenever
I'm trying to read data from these guys
or send signals there is some time delay
this time delay can capture many things
such as the delay from reading the
sensor information and uploading it as
well as the fact that the cloud system
itself cannot really run in real-time
that sounds really surprising but if you
think about it if I have a hundred
thousand homes and I'm sending signals
to all of them and trying to run in a
cloud from Google it has to have a
certain reliability that it doesn't
require today when you are looking at a
Netflix video and buffering and so on so
forth and this was an observation
actually from Google itself when they
were trying to build a system like this
for storage okay so what we have as a
challenge is one we have this delay
potentially we would like our solution
to look like this Holmes or the D our
provider does some optimization himself
without having to know everything about
the network and the coordinator who
knows everything about the network
somehow doesn't need to tell what all of
these guys have to do but provide some
enough information that can help them
but then it's running at a much slower
time scale okay and that's kind of the
algorithm that we came up with and this
is actually Kyl figure this out trying
it out actually this is the surprising
part and the algorithm is kind of simple
in the cloud what you're going to do is
you're gonna take run a model predictive
control so you're going to just predict
what all these homes are gonna do in the
aggregate and then you're going to just
find a nominal solution for your
optimization take into account all the
network constraints and that's what we
call here the global optimum you can
maybe also generate various scenarios so
that you can sample all the possible
trajectories for these homes and now if
I know that the homes are going to vary
in different scenarios I can also
calculate things like a bound so I can
try to figure out if the net injection
on every node is between certain limits
is it going to it's going to be a safe
operating state for the network I don't
really care what you do but as long as
you keep between these bounds so this is
kind of the bounds optimization the
surprising part here is that you to do
this it's quite complicated if I have to
take into account all of the homes
simultaneously so what we do is we fix
everybody add this nominal operating
point and then try to find the bound for
each home okay this is our empirical
strategy and then the local controller
all does it all that it receives two
pieces of information one kind of a
normal trajectory that would be good for
a home to follow if it is trying to
minimize cost and second these actual
bounds but then it actually can take
decisions must much faster and in real
time so it runs its own optimization so
this is the control strategy I'm gonna
skip all of this and basically what we
find is that this strategy works very
well so here is kind of one metric of
this I'm having different delays in the
cloud and this is the arbitrage profit
and you can see here these are all the
values are very close to each other but
even if I'm delayed by 24 hours so I'm
running this cloud once a day ok still
the system does extremely well and this
is not just for this numerical example
we have tried it for a few other
networks and so on and similarly you can
see the
compared to no coordination no matter
what the delay is this coordinated
mechanism has a far lower rate of
voltage violations similarly here's kind
of a different levels of storage so we
tried simulation wise adding different
amounts of storage into the system and
again you can see a huge gain from the
coordination and finally kind of a
surprising result for us which is what
made us spend a lot of time to kind of
improve this method and decide to try it
out in the real world in practice was
this particular result so here I have
different levels of storage penetration
and this is the actual total arbitrage
profit of the obtained by all the homes
this maximum assumes that everything is
known so we call it perfect foresight so
there's no stochasticity and the network
is known centrally and you run the
centralized optimization and then black
is the coordinated version okay so
that's kind of very very close and in
fact it's about 80% we are able to
accrue on average about 80% of the
optimum with this simple scheme and we
actually also have been testing out what
happens if we want the homes not just to
minimize cost but to follow different
patterns like ramps and different types
of signals so right now what what we
found a bunch of empirical consequences
of this type of things these an
algorithm like this allows you to find
out do you need a lot of storage or
little storage where to place storage
and things like that but also can be
used in the real world so we have an
arpa-e project that is helping test this
in a real-world setting and implement
implementing it and testing it but one
question that we have been looking into
but it is quite interesting and it seems
quite hard is how do you analyze the
performance of this architecture and if
you have this type of constraint
what is the optimal decision procedure
so it's kind of in-between decentralized
control and distributed control so it's
kind of a mixed architecture but maybe
through some simplifications or
something like that this could be lead
to some insight in fact there were some
recent papers by Nicola Matney who was
here a few moments ago that looked at a
similar architecture but not the same
but if you try the design they had and
the particular signals they were sending
it did not do so well here so again
there's a lot to be understood for
things that work well versus things that
are theoretically sound I think that's
one of the messages here so that's the
conclusion here I'm happy to talk to you
guys about this and I think in power
systems today if you look at everything
that's happening in practice there's a
series of algorithms that have been
tuned empirically with very little
explanation and there's a bunch of
theoretical stuff that doesn't always
work in the real world so that's kind of
where we are right now okay
[Applause]
yeah so so in the state estimation
literature what they have what they
assume is that there may be some
switches whose position is unknown and
then you may go about finding it
greedily if you apply if you apply that
for for example for the radial system
you will obtain this but there's another
big difference between these two as far
as I can say typically in state
estimation they're considering a
one-shot problem you're not allowed to
use the information over time so if I
only have a one shot I can't really run
any of these methods but if you
considered the information over time put
it through the traditional state
estimator and you say okay I want to
minimize these squares and I want to
find these discrete variables these
methods are approximations to that and
this is kind of a known result in stats
yeah you can use more than one shot
that's right that's right so this is why
we focus on this distribution system
case in this example because it gives
you a little bit more constraints
maybe we should centrum again
[Applause]